here on the northeastern edge of South
America lies an outpost of France where
in the cooler tropical evenings they
relax as they might do in Paris or not
but this is cairn in French Guiana and
the launch point of a unique expedition
to explore and dive the whole new world
we jump on the expedition rib and head
out to see the ship were to join is
lying 20 kilometers offshore the
Esperanza is one of green pieces
campaign vessels and right now a dive
ship and a floating laboratory combined
so the Amazon River and the Amazon mouth
is here the Amazon reef presence was
first revealed two years ago off the
coast of Brazil here with a first
Greenpeace expedition in the area and a
second Greenpeace expedition in the area
last year identified the reef presence
also into French Guiana waters we head
off to find it no one has died these
seas before this expedition
almost immediately were accompanied at
the bow by a school of dolphins just
joining for the ride these waters are
brimming full of life a sonar device
they call the fish is launched and scans
the seabed it images anxiously observed
on deck we're scanning the bottom of the
ocean between 80 100 120 meter to find
if there's a rock base please that reef
this expedition is not alone with an
interest in what lies below now 500
kilometers in that direction lies the
mouth of the Amazon and Brazilian waters
where it's estimated up to 14 billion
barrels of oil lie and companies like BP
and the Brazilian government for that
matter they want to get at it and the
fear is that should there be an oil
spill the great outpouring of the Amazon
River which is the world's largest we'll
send that spill up in this direction
destroying pristine ecosystem is given
more argument to the global call for
marine conservation and creating marine
protected areas this is one of the kind
of priority area we need to protect in
the world because you have iconic
species you are vulnerable ecosystem so
that's a way to call the global leaders
for marine Patek
meanwhile the sonar team have found a
section of reef suitable for diving you
can see some heel we got up to six seven
meter high reef at the bottom so that's
clearly some interesting some
interesting area to go in and dive over
there so time to prepare the dive kit
for an early morning mission to the deep
who knows what the new day will bring
Nick Clark al-jazeera off the coast of
French Guiana